Jake:吃啥呢
Jake: What are you eating?
Jake: 你不吃
Jake: You're not eating?
Jake: 呵呵吃吧
Jake: Haha, go ahead and eat.
Jake: 你也不吃
Jake: You're not eating either?
Jake: 就咱俩吃
Jake: It's just the two of us eating.
Lucia: 有可能但我其实肯定也吃不了多少
Lucia: Maybe, but I probably can't eat much anyway.
Lucia: 但如果完全不吃我可能晚上睡觉
Lucia: But if I don't eat at all, I might not sleep well tonight.
Jake:那咱吃夜宵吧
Jake: Then let's have a midnight snack.
Jake: 要不哈哈哈
Jake: How about that, haha.
Lucia: 就是你选择吃什么吧
Lucia: You choose what to eat.
Lucia:哈哈我都行
Lucia: Haha, I'm fine with anything.
Katrina: 我想喝粥
Katrina: I want porridge.
Jake:咱都吃馄饨呗
Jake: Let's all have wontons.
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Katrina: 呵呵呵
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia:我算完了老板
Lucia: I'm done, boss.
Lucia:哈哈好
Lucia: Haha, okay.
Alice:请
Alice: Please.
Lucia:要给你发详单吗
Lucia: Do you want me to send you the detailed bill?
Jake:可以 好好
Jake: Sure, okay.
Lucia:654.78
Lucia: 654.78.
Katrina: 你怎么花这么少钱
Katrina: How did you spend so little money?
Lucia:啊 我的
Lucia: Ah, it's mine.
Jake:害怕
Jake: Scary.
Lucia:可能是因为我我没有怎么点过外卖
Lucia: Maybe it's because I haven't really ordered takeout much.
Lucia:我每次都是大家点的时候
Lucia: Every time others order,
Lucia:我就跟着点一个
Lucia: I just follow and order one.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia:我甚至觉得我这个挺多
Lucia: I even think I have quite a lot.
Lucia:因为我加了我的疫苗
Lucia: Because I got my vaccine.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:谢谢老板 实际上我还要在打两针呢
Lucia: Thanks boss. Actually, I still need to get two more shots.
Jake:好好好行 没问题
Jake: Okay, okay, no problem.
Katrina: 走上去一看就是一堆capo
Katrina: When you look up, it's just a bunch of capo.
Lucia:我在接下来这一个月里还要打两针
Lucia: I still need to get two more shots in the next month.
Jake:好痛
Jake: Ouch.
Shure的女友:你问他嘛想要强盗
Shure's GF: You should ask him if he wants to be a robber.
Katrina: 可能他想要体验一下女生的这种感觉
Katrina: Maybe he wants to experience what it's like to be a girl.
Katrina: 但你穿的竟然还好
Katrina: But what you're wearing is actually fine.
Katrina: 够了哈哈哈
Katrina: Enough, hahaha.
Katrina: 快走吧
Katrina: Let's go quickly.
Katrina: 修硕哈哈
Katrina: Shure, haha.
Katrina: 被你折磨的
Katrina: You're torturing me.
Katrina: 拜拜
Katrina: Bye-bye.
Shure: 拜拜
Shure: Bye-bye.
Katrina: 别哭别哭
Katrina: Don't cry, don't cry.
Katrina: 哈哈哈别哭
Katrina: Hahaha, don't cry.
Katrina: 哈哈哈还下雨吗
Katrina: Hahaha, is it still raining?
Shure: 不下啦
Shure: It's not raining anymore.
Katrina: ok
Katrina: Ok.
Alice:刚刚下雨了吗
Alice: Was it raining just now?
Lucia:刚下了哇
Lucia: It just rained, wow.
Jake:再见了两位拜拜
Jake: Goodbye, you two, bye.
Shure: 怎么还出门相送呢
Shure: Why are you seeing us off?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:拜拜
Jake: Bye-bye.
Jake:拜拜 别回来了
Jake: Bye, don't come back.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Katrina: 把我笑死了
Katrina: You're killing me with laughter.
Katrina: 拜拜你回来了
Katrina: Bye, you're back.
Jake:拜拜 哈哈
Jake: Bye, haha.
Katrina: 生怕他们再回来烧钱
Katrina: Afraid they'll come back and waste money.
Katrina: 我去算我的钱
Katrina: I'll go count my money.
Alice:收拾东西
Alice: Pack up your stuff.
Jake:来 收款码
Jake: Here, the payment code.
Lucia:嗯谢谢老板
Lucia: Hmm, thanks, boss.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia:等一下啊
Lucia: Wait a second.
Lucia:哦好像是这个
Lucia: Oh, I think it's this one.
Alice:现在是要一个
Alice: Now we need one...
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Alice:一个什么吗
Alice: One what?
Alice:怎么报账
Alice: How do we report this?
Alice:是给你账单
Alice: Should I give you the bill?
Lucia:自自己加一下也行
Lucia: You can just add it yourself.
Lucia:哈哈哈对给一个
Lucia: Haha, yeah, give one.
Jake:然后后来给一个账单也行
Jake: Then you can give the bill later.
Lucia:行行
Lucia: Sure, sure.
Jake:对
Jake: Yep.
Jake:给一个
Jake: Give one.
Lucia:但是我这都是就是
Lucia: But I have all these...
Lucia:微信淘宝然后京东这些
Lucia: WeChat, Taobao, and JD stuff.
Jake:OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Alice:哎呀别烦我
Alice: Hey, don't bother me.
Jake:多少来着
Jake: How much was it again?
Jake:行
Jake: Alright.
Jake:600
Jake: 600.
Lucia:我看一眼上哪去了 654.78
Lucia: Let me check... 654.78.
Jake:可以很精确谢谢
Jake: Wow, very precise, thanks.
Lucia:我在卫生所
Lucia: I'm at the clinic.
Lucia:那是有发票的
Lucia: There are receipts for that.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:需要的话可以给你
Lucia: If you need them, I can give you.
Jake:用不着
Jake: No need.
Alice:你可以帮我按一下计算器吗我不想
Alice: Can you help me press the calculator? I don't want to.
Lucia:可以可以
Lucia: Sure, sure.
Alice:我来吧
Alice: I'll do it.
Jake:记账台是吧
Jake: This is the accounting desk, right?
Jake:这就是账台
Jake: This is the desk.
Jake:记账台
Jake: The accounting desk.
Lucia:我们也要做balance shit吗难道
Lucia: Do we also need to do a balance sheet?
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia:梯子帐
Lucia: Ladder accounts.
Alice:好啦我把账直接发给你吧
Alice: Okay, I'll send the invoice directly to you.
Jake: 好 呃 你这个很专业
Jake: Okay, um, this is really professional.
Alice:这是备忘录
Alice: This is a memo.
Alice:就是你可以放图片和文字
Alice: You can add pictures and text in it.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:嗯学习学习
Lucia: Hmm, got to learn this.
Alice:这个
Alice: This...
Katrina: 哎呀哎我们直接算了
Katrina: Oh my, let's just calculate it directly.
Katrina: 你需要我们订单纸那个吗
Katrina: Do you need the order paper?
Alice:备忘录里写也行
Alice: Writing in the memo is fine too.
Katrina: 他不需要的话我们就直接算了
Katrina: If he doesn't need it, let's just calculate it directly.
Katrina: 我先点个粥喝
Katrina: I'll order some porridge first.
Katrina: 看我的红包
Katrina: Look at my red envelope.
Lucia:我也可以用
Lucia: I can use it too.
Katrina: 一个一新币的红包
Katrina: A red envelope with one Singapore dollar.
Jake:嗯啊很多哈哈
Jake: Hmm, that's a lot, haha.
Alice:咦
Alice: Huh?
Alice:奇怪呢
Alice: That's strange.
Alice:我给你发一个
Alice: I'll send you one.
Alice:为什么是这样的呢
Alice: Why is it like this?
Alice:给你发一个完整版的
Alice: I'll send you the complete version.
Katrina: 你们吃啥
Katrina: What are you guys eating?
Jake:呃就你那个店里边
Jake: Uh, just from your store.
Jake:我们再找一找
Jake: We'll look around.
Katrina: 我吃如意馄饨
Katrina: I'm having Ru Yi wontons.
Katrina: 你们也吃馄饨吗
Katrina: Are you guys having wontons too?
Katrina: 你们想吃别的可以点
Katrina: You can order something else if you want.
Jake:就是吃馄饨
Jake: Just wontons.
Jake:大家也没什么想
Jake: Nobody has any other ideas.
Jake:你们想吃什么也行
Jake: You can eat whatever you want.
Jake:馄饨就是它
Jake: Wontons it is.
Alice:算了直接截图吧
Alice: Forget it, let's just take a screenshot.
Lucia:我也要这个吧
Lucia: I'll have this too.
Lucia:我要香菜
Lucia: I want cilantro.
Katrina: 你吃吗嗯
Katrina: Are you eating?
Katrina: 你不想吃
Katrina: You don't want to eat?
Katrina: 你呢
Katrina: What about you?
Jake:一碗大馄饨50一颗
Jake: A bowl of big wontons, 50 each.
Jake:有上楼
Jake: Going upstairs.
Jake:随便拔
Jake: Just pull it out.
Alice:我也弄成PDF
Alice: I'll also make it into a PDF.
Jake:好好你来
Jake: Alright, you go ahead.
Jake:哈哈哈你拔了
Jake: Haha, you pulled it out.
Alice:因为 那个
Alice: Because that...
Alice:一弄就变马那啥了
Alice: Once you do it, it turns into a mess.
Lucia:嗯截止到目前为止
Lucia: Hmm, up to this point...
Lucia:我一个人要的香菜啊
Lucia: I'm the only one who wanted cilantro.
Jake:嘿嘿
Jake: Hehe.
Lucia:没事它是一份一份的对
Lucia: It's okay, it's just one portion, right?
Jake:呵呵对
Jake: Haha, yeah.
Jake:你你你给我哎哎我靠
Jake: You, you, give it to me. Whoa, damn.
Jake:呃 唧 好
Jake: Uh, okay.
Jake:给钱哈哈
Jake: Give me money, haha.
Tasha:我靠
Tasha: Damn.
Tasha:那还不够还的
Tasha: That's not enough.
Jake:打钱够不够
Jake: Is transferring money enough?
Jake:看看
Jake: Check it.
Tasha:没没坏吧
Tasha: It's not broken, right?
Alice:那就行
Alice: Then it's fine.
Alice:白干
Alice: Worked for nothing.
Jake:白干哈哈哈那何止白干
Jake: Worked for nothing, haha. It's more than just working for nothing.
Tasha:何止白干
Tasha: More than just working for nothing.
Jake:那何止白干
Jake: It's more than just working for nothing.
Tasha:大钱没进
Tasha: No big money came in.
Lucia:有种跟拼
Lucia: It's like working for Pinduoduo.
Lucia:有种在   打工
Lucia: It's like working for Pinduoduo and signing a non-compete agreement.
Lucia:然后签了竞业协议的感觉
Lucia: And signing a non-compete agreement.
Alice:给
Alice: Here.
Lucia:你们知道那个梗吗
Lucia: You guys know that joke?
Alice:你挑一个
Alice: You pick one.
Lucia:   就是
Lucia: Pinduoduo is...
Lucia:哇我这能说吗
Lucia: Wow, can I say this?
Katrina: 楼上也没有多的充电宝
Katrina: There's no extra power bank upstairs.
Lucia:是影响他们的品牌形象啊
Lucia:就是前几天
Lucia: Just a few days ago...
Jake:楼上没有充电宝啊
Jake: There's no power bank upstairs?
Katrina: 都是插了这种的
Katrina: They are all plugged in.
Katrina: 充电宝插了摄像机的
Katrina: The power banks are plugged into the cameras.
Jake:对对对是的
Jake: Yeah, yeah, they are.
Katrina: 你可以
Katrina: You can...
Jake:基本上不录了
Jake: Basically, we’re not recording anymore.
Lucia:楼上的那个摄像机好像关了是吧
Lucia: The camera upstairs seems to be off, right?
Jake: 对楼上的不录了
Jake: Yeah, we’re not recording upstairs.
Lucia:就是前前
Lucia: So, earlier on...
Alice:所以怎么弄成PDF呢
Alice: So, how do we make it into a PDF?
Jake:呃打印
Jake: Uh, print it.
Lucia:那 嗯备忘录吗
Lucia: Then, um, the memo?
Lucia:备忘录好像可以直接导出成品
Lucia: I think you can directly export the memo as a file.
Alice:导出备忘录我发出的这张图片
Alice: Export the memo and the image I sent.
Jake:来来来来来
Jake: Come, come, come.
Alice:哦 它已经好了
Alice: Oh, it’s done.
Jake:来给你
Jake: Here you go.
Jake:您您继续说我右手的指
Jake: Please continue, my right hand is...
Alice:我我我怎么弄
Alice: How do I do this?
Lucia:啊没事
Lucia: Ah, it’s fine.
Jake:你放这我再给你
Jake: You put it here, I’ll give it to you.
Jake:我给你秀一下
Jake: Let me show you.
Jake:哎接着吧别忘录
Jake: Hey, keep going, don’t forget to record.
Alice:然后就打印
Alice: And then just print it.
Alice:哦这样啊
Alice: Oh, like this.
Alice:对然后呢
Alice: Right, and then?
Jake:然后选择打印机
Jake: Then choose the printer.
Jake:哦也不用
Jake: Oh, we don't need that.
Jake:就这边直接点
Jake: Just click here directly.
Jake:就可以发送了
Jake: And you can send it.
Jake:这边是pdf
Jake: This is a PDF.
Katrina: 我手机呢
Katrina: Where's my phone?
Lucia:啊哦就是就是
Lucia: Oh, right, right.
Lucia:前几天网上一个新闻就是
Lucia: A few days ago, there was news online about Pinduoduo.
Lucia:就是大家知道竟业协议这回事
Lucia: You guys know about non-compete agreements?
Lucia:嗯对靖康可能知道
Lucia: Yeah, maybe Jingkang knows.
Lucia:就是啊
Lucia: So, um...
Lucia:薇薇之前不知道的话就是没事
Lucia: If Tasha didn't know about it before, it's fine.
Lucia:这个反正是你到到工作的时候
Lucia: Anyway, it's something you'll deal with when you start working.
Lucia:之后才会才会用到
Lucia: You'll only need it later on.
Lucia:所以然后就是有的大公司
Lucia: So, some big companies...
Lucia:比如说就为了防止你入入职
Lucia: For example, to prevent you from joining a competitor...
Lucia:跟他有竞争关系的其他公司
Lucia: They make you sign a non-compete agreement when you join.
Lucia:他在入职时候会跟你签竞业协议就要
Lucia: It's to prevent senior employees from leaking business secrets.
Lucia:就是防止就是这些高层员工泄露商业
Lucia:商业机密
Lucia:他本身是这样的一个
Lucia: He's just that kind of person.
Lucia:就是design purpose是这个
Lucia: The design purpose is like this.
Lucia:然后但是就是
Lucia: But then...
Lucia:有的公司现在就开始滥用这个
Lucia: Some companies now are abusing this.
Lucia:就是即使是基层员工入职
Lucia: Even for entry-level employees.
Lucia:比如说刚刚刚毕业应届生这种
Lucia: Like fresh graduates.
Lucia:也让他们去签竞业协议
Lucia: They make them sign non-compete agreements.
Lucia:然后因为其实现在就是大家换工
Lucia: Because job-hopping is pretty common nowadays.
Lucia:换工作是很常见的嘛
Lucia: So, there were cases before...
Lucia:然后就有之前就有好好好些
Lucia: Where some very ordinary employees...
Lucia:就是其实很普通的员工
Lucia: After they left their jobs...
Lucia:然后他们可能从这公司离职之后
Lucia: They joined new companies that...
Lucia:然后他进入了一个实际上吧
Lucia: Don't even deal with their previous company's business.
Lucia:他负责的业务
Lucia: The work they do...
Lucia:可能跟之前公司也不是那么相关的
Lucia: Is not even related to their old company.
Lucia:这么的新公司
Lucia: And they're just entry-level workers...
Lucia:然后就是而且他们就是基层打工人
Lucia: So they don't have any trade secrets.
Lucia:所以手上也没有什么商业机密
Lucia: But their former employers...
Lucia:但是他们的员工司
Lucia: Use the non-compete agreement to sue them.
Lucia:就拿这个竞业协议去起诉他们
Lucia: And make them pay compensation.
Lucia:然后让他们赔钱
Lucia: So it's like working for nothing.
Lucia:就相当于是白干
Lucia: It's even worse...
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:对相当于不光白干
Lucia: Yeah, it's like working for nothing.
Lucia:还要给员工公司赔钱
Lucia: And having to pay the company.
Lucia:就这个事情
Lucia: This thing...
Lucia:前段时间
Lucia: Recently...
Lucia:反正网上说了好几个这样的例子
Lucia: There have been several examples online.
Lucia:都是我刚才说的那个
Lucia: Just like what I mentioned.
Lucia:我就不说一遍了
Lucia: I won't repeat it.
Lucia:这样一会你方便剪
Lucia: So it's easier for you to edit later.
Lucia:哈哈哈好好
Lucia: Haha, okay.
Lucia:我场记一下
Lucia: I'll make a note of this.
Lucia:我还是挺害怕他们来找我的
Lucia: I'm still quite afraid they'll come after me.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice:我没有
Alice: I'm not.
Jake:没有没有我把
Jake: No, no...
Jake:我们把   给逼掉就行
Jake: We'll just bleep out Pinduoduo.
Jake:我们把逼给逼掉就行
Jake: We'll just bleep out the name.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Alice:杨老板我来算算你八字吧
Alice: Jake, let me read your fortune.
Jake:啊好啊
Jake: Oh, sure.
Jake:怎么算
Jake: How do you do it?
Katrina: 感觉你有点小魔女的感觉
Katrina: You seem a bit like a little witch.
Jake:请坐请坐
Jake: Have a seat, have a seat.
Alice:哦不用不用不用不用不用不用不用哎呀
Alice: Oh no no no no no no no...
Jake:请坐大师
Jake: Have a seat, master.
Jake:大师请坐
Jake: Master, please sit.
Jake:哈哈大师不得坐着的
Jake: Haha, masters don't sit.
Jake:站着大师
Jake: Stand up, master.
Jake:没见过站着大师
Jake: Never seen a standing master.
Alice:但你得
Alice: But you need...
Lucia:但是
Lucia: But...
Alice:你知道你的出生时间吗
Alice: Do you know your birth time?
Jake:我好像不知道
Jake: I don't think I do.
Alice:那拜
Alice: Then bye.
Jake:好再见
Jake: Okay, goodbye.
Alice:白搭 直接白搭
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Katrina: 可以算我的吗
Katrina: Can you read mine?
Katrina: 我知道我是农历还是阳历
Katrina: I know if it's lunar or solar calendar.
Katrina: 呃你得出精确到时间
Katrina: Um, you need to be precise with the time.
Katrina: 我下午1点出生的
Katrina: I was born at 1 PM.
Katrina: 下午1点可以
Katrina: 1 PM is fine.
Alice:1点前一点后
Alice: Before 1 PM or after?
Katrina: 一点零几分了
Katrina: A few minutes past 1.
Lucia:不过法律意义上说我这应该不算造谣
Lucia: But legally speaking, this shouldn't count as slander.
Lucia:因为
Lucia: Because...
Lucia:我只是复述了我在网上看到的信息
Lucia: I'm just repeating what I saw online.
Alice:那你的生日是
Alice: So your birthday is...
Katrina: 嗯阳历还是农历
Katrina: Hmm, lunar or solar?
Katrina: 阳历2001
Katrina: Solar, 2001.
Lucia:反正我好多同学都是学法的
Lucia: Anyway, many of my classmates studied law.
Lucia:都够组一个律师团了
Lucia: They could form a legal team.
Alice:91年12月
Alice: December 1991.
Katrina: 21
Katrina: 21st.
Lucia:下午1点
Lucia: 1 PM.
Alice:1点啊 1点无所谓
Alice: 1 PM, it doesn't matter.
Alice:1点几分都一样
Alice: A few minutes past 1, it's all the same.
Tasha:现在在干嘛
Tasha: What are you doing now?
Katrina: 现在等饭
Katrina: Waiting for food.
Tasha:哦对你们点饭了 哎
Tasha: Oh right, you ordered food, huh?
Lucia:你刚才没点吗
Lucia: Didn't you order earlier?
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Katrina: 那你可以睡觉
Katrina: Then you can sleep.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Tasha:好
Tasha: Okay.
Katrina: 今天睡了一下午好爽啊
Katrina: Slept the whole afternoon today, felt so good.
Jake:是确实
Jake: Yeah, for sure.
Katrina: 而且醒来都都下雨了
Katrina: And when I woke up, it was raining.
Jake:下雨天适合睡觉
Jake: Rainy days are perfect for sleeping.
Alice:请求超时
Alice: Request timed out.
Alice:我们是现场报销吗
Alice: Do we get reimbursed on the spot?
Jake:可以
Jake: Yes.
Katrina: 哎呦 哎我买一支彩色笔好像没看见
Katrina: Oh, I bought a colored pen but didn't see it.
Katrina: 一支彩色笔 没送吗
Katrina: A colored pen, didn't they deliver it?
Lucia:没送吗
Lucia: Didn't they deliver it?
Katrina: 哎取了取了
Katrina: Oh, I got it.
Katrina: 我听谁说好像看见了
Katrina: I heard someone say they saw it.
Lucia:好像看了但是
Lucia: They might have seen it but...
Lucia:后来又放哪去就不知道了
Lucia: Then put it somewhere and forgot.
Jake:这边还有一袋
Jake: There's another bag here.
Jake:不知道是什么
Jake: Don't know what's inside.
Jake:不知道谁垫的
Jake: Don't know who put it here.
Katrina: 我的我的
Katrina: It's mine, mine.
Katrina: 我今天早上找我的牙膏没找到
Katrina: I couldn't find my toothpaste this morning.
Lucia:哦我还买了碘伏和生理盐水
Lucia: Oh, I also bought iodine and saline.
Lucia:不过那东西会也只有我用了
Lucia: But I'm the only one using them.
Lucia:没事就算我那个啥也行
Lucia: It's fine, even if I'm the only one.
Lucia:反正他也就一新币
Lucia: Anyway, it was just one dollar.
Tasha:一新币
Tasha: One dollar?
Lucia:对一新币
Lucia: Yes, one dollar.
Lucia:算了不管他了
Lucia: Forget it, doesn't matter.
Lucia:不算了
Lucia: Nevermind.
Jake:对回新加坡少坐一次公交车
Jake: Yeah, back in Singapore, it's like skipping one bus ride.
Jake:少坐半次公交车
Jake: Or half a bus ride less.
Katrina: 然后我还买了花呢
Katrina: And I bought flowers too.
Lucia:我美团上的单子比较少刚就忘
Lucia: I had fewer orders on Meituan, so I forgot.
Lucia:算了不也没关系
Lucia: It's fine, doesn't matter.
Lucia:哈哈哈不用
Lucia: Hahaha, no need.
Lucia:争取用这个哈哈哈
Lucia: Let's try to use this, hahaha.
Lucia:觉得我现在又饱又饿好奇怪啊
Lucia: I feel both full and hungry, it's so weird.
Jake:就是几个胃
Jake: It's like having several stomachs.
Lucia:其实我有点想吃东西
Lucia: Actually, I kind of want to eat something.
Lucia:但是就是我没有那种特别饿的感觉
Lucia: But I don't really feel super hungry.
Alice:上面还有提拉米苏
Alice: There's still tiramisu left upstairs.
Lucia:刚才吃了一大块
Lucia: I just had a big piece.
Tasha:好腻刚刚吃了一块
Tasha: It's so rich, I just had a piece.
Jake:最多吃一个
Jake: One is more than enough.
Alice:很甜蜜
Alice: It's very sweet.
Jake:那确实一天最多吃一个
Jake: Yeah, you can only have one a day.
Lucia:很好吃但是吃多了确实会有一点
Lucia: It's really delicious but if you eat too much, it gets a bit...
Lucia:太甜了
Lucia: Too sweet.
Lucia:糖分摄入超标
Lucia: Sugar intake overload.
Tasha:然后今天晚上就把房子拆了就行是吧
Tasha: So we just need to demolish the house tonight, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Tasha:那我现在去拆
Tasha: I'll go demolish it now.
Tasha:然后晚上就不用拆了
Tasha: Then we won't need to do it tonight.
Jake:对 好
Jake: Yes, good.
Jake:现在拆吧
Jake: Do it now.
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Sure, go ahead.
Tasha:你也拆
Tasha: You too, demolish.
Alice:报账吗老板
Alice: Boss, can I get reimbursed?
Jake:可以报
Jake: You can.
Lucia:我也拆
Lucia: I'll demolish too.
Jake:怎么报
Jake: How to reimburse?
Jake:就你你给我那PDF你写一个
Jake: Just give me the PDF, write it up.
Jake:总帐呗
Jake: The total account.
Katrina: 我这个太杂了
Katrina: Mine is so messy.
Katrina: 我天
Katrina: Oh my god.
Alice:就在568.19 刚摁的这些线
Alice: It's just 568.19, these lines I just pressed.
Jake:就就这些是吧 对
Jake: Just these, right? Yes.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Jake:好
Jake: Good.
Jake:恭喜结账成功
Jake: Congrats on completing the billing.
Alice:OK了
Alice: All set.
Alice:哇听见田螺姑娘了
Alice: Wow, I hear the snail girl.
Alice:你是在帮我
Alice: Are you helping me?
Alice:哇塞
Alice: Wow.
Alice:真爱上了
Alice: I'm really in love.
Alice:我真爱上你了
Alice: I've really fallen in love with you.
Alice:我这样像同性恋吗
Alice: Do I look like a lesbian like this? 性别问题
Alice:不太像我觉得
Alice: Not really, I think.
Alice:you
Alice: you
Alice:高级吗
Alice: Is it fancy?
Alice:我要花朝里外
Alice: I want the flowers inside and out.
Alice:回去还得洗
Alice: I'll have to wash it when I get back.
Alice:你叠的有褶褶
Alice: You folded it with creases.
Alice:算算算就这样
Alice: Never mind, let's leave it like this.
Alice:枕头套呢
Alice: Where's the pillowcase?
Jake:  还没算完
Jake: Not done counting yet.
Jake:我靠 害怕了
Jake: Oh my, I'm scared.
Katrina: 哈哈有很多小东西
Katrina: Haha, there are many small items.
Katrina: 然后各个平台
Katrina: And then each platform.
Katrina: 我点过饭
Katrina: I ordered food.
Katrina: 也帮忙付过超市的钱
Katrina: Also helped pay for groceries.
Jake:害怕你妈给我这么长一个账单吗
Jake: Are you afraid your mom will give me such a long bill?
Katrina: 不止在计算机里呢
Katrina: It's not just in the computer.
Jake:拿球球是啥玩意
Jake: What's this ball thing?
Katrina: 嗯没记
Katrina: Hmm, didn't record.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Oh my.
Katrina: 这样的今天晚上做个pdf
Katrina: We'll make a PDF tonight.
Katrina: 一个超市400多
Katrina: One supermarket trip was over 400.
Jake:我看大件大件都是啥
Jake: Let me see what the big expenses are.
Jake:大的大花销都是啥
Jake: What are the big expenses?
Katrina: 两两顿饭
Katrina: Two meals.
Katrina: 然后房子预算那500
Katrina: Then the house budget was 500.
Katrina: 嗯拉满了
Katrina: Yeah, maxed out.
Katrina: 然后买那个花什么的那边300多
Katrina: And then buying flowers or something, that was over 300.
Katrina: 300多然后那个超市450好像
Katrina: Over 300, and the supermarket was 450, I think.
Katrina: 然后饭点了一顿170
Katrina: Then one meal was 170.
Katrina: 然后点了一顿120
Katrina: And another meal was 120.
Jake:你刚都录下来了
Jake: Did you record all that?
Jake:反正就是是吧
Jake: Anyway, right?
Jake:那行
Jake: Alright then.
Jake:回头就这个单独的任务给你做一个
Jake: Later, I'll give you this separate task.
Jake:一千六百九十二点
Jake: One thousand six hundred ninety-two point...
Katrina: 一六九二点二
Katrina: One thousand six hundred ninety-two point two.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
刘婷:有点
Liu Ting: A little bit.
Alice:但我没有别的了
Alice: But I don't have anything else.
Alice:最多也就加一层
Alice: At most, I can add one more layer.
Jake:你这连续三个2
Jake: You got three 2s in a row.
Jake:刚刚也有一个连续三个6
Jake: Just now, you also got three 6s in a row.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Katrina: 啊那就0.17
Katrina: Ah, then it's 0.17.
Jake:喂
Jake: Hello.
Jake:在结个工资
Jake: About the salary settlement.
Jake:还有个抢过什么红包
Jake: And something about the red envelopes.
Katrina: 我好像抢了两三个
Katrina: I think I grabbed two or three.
Jake: 我靠
Jake: Damn.
Katrina: 你直接拿2100减这个吧
Katrina: Just deduct this directly from 2100.
Jake:嗯嗯嗯
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake:其实是你们最后四天
Jake: Actually, it's your last four days.
Jake:怎么了
Jake: What's up?
Katrina: 我抢了985啊
Katrina: I grabbed 985, right?
Jake:真的985 呵呵呵
Jake: Really, 985? Haha.
Jake:牛逼
Jake: Impressive.
Katrina: 那就2,100减985
Katrina: Then it's 2,100 minus 985.
Katrina: 哎不是2,000
Katrina: Wait, no, not 2,000.
Katrina: 是两
Katrina: It's...
Jake:我我来算一下
Jake: Let me calculate it.
Jake:就是其实是最后四天
Jake: Actually, it's the last four days.
Jake:最后四天没有没结账
Jake: The last four days weren't settled.
Jake:四天是1,200
Jake: The four days are 1,200.
Jake:然后你抢了个 啥也没抢
Jake: Then you grabbed nothing.
Jake:那你就是1,200
Jake: So you get 1,200.
Jake:就是从
Jake: From...
Jake:周五周五周六周日周一这四天
Jake: Friday, Saturday, Sunday, Monday, these four days.
Jake:一共1,200
Jake: Total is 1,200.
Jake:然后这四天你一个红包都没抢着
Jake: And you didn't grab any red envelopes these four days.
Katrina: 我前面抢了一个74一个300的
Katrina: I grabbed one for 74 and one for 300 earlier.
Jake:对就是前面
Jake: Yeah, those were earlier.
Jake:周五之前的就清掉了
Jake: Everything before Friday was cleared.
Jake:你还抢了74
Jake: You also grabbed 74.
Katrina: 74是第一天
Katrina: 74 was the first day.
Katrina: 你说你发错了
Katrina: You said you made a mistake.
Jake:发错了 OK 发错了
Jake: Made a mistake. OK, it was a mistake.
Jake:74 你发错了
Jake: 74, you made a mistake.
Jake:那就给你扣74
Jake: Okay, I'll deduct 74 for you.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Jake:哎你74也还给我了
Jake: Hey, you gave me back the 74.
Katrina: 但你没收啊
Katrina: But you didn't take it.
Jake:啊行行行
Jake: Ah, okay, okay, okay.
Jake:嗯嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Jake:有钱了
Jake: Got money now.
Jake:可以坐飞机回家了
Jake: We can take a flight home.
Katrina: 哈哈哈真的
Katrina: Hahaha, really?
Jake:可以可以到机场这边取机票
Jake: Yeah, we can get the tickets at the airport.
Jake:在玩猫吗
Jake: Are you playing with the cat?
Jake:砸的不够远
Jake: Didn't throw it far enough.
Jake:砸他脑袋上了
Jake: Hit it on the head.
Tasha:收拾完了 啊我可以摘眼镜了吗
Tasha: Finished cleaning up. Can I take off my glasses now?
Jake:你玩会猫
Tasha:你这些拿的都不是他爱吃的
Tasha: The stuff you got isn't what it likes to eat.
Jake:那它爱吃啥  肉
Jake: Then what does it like? Meat?
Tasha:对 有吗
Tasha: Yes, do you have any?
Jake:我没有肉 我还能有肉
Jake: I don't have meat. How could I have meat?
Jake:外边有只猫
Jake: There's a cat outside.
Jake:喂猫的
Jake: Feeding the cat.
Alice:真的吗
Alice: Really?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm.
Alice:老板你还需要什么打扫的吗
Alice: Boss, do you need any more cleaning?
Alice:我们走了之后可就没人给你打扫
Alice: Once we leave, no one will clean for you.
Jake:嗯 我觉得
Jake: Mm, I think...
Jake: 很好
Jake: It's good.
Jake:你觉得呢
Jake: What do you think?
Alice:我不知道啊
Alice: I don't know.
Jake:我觉得我觉得我打扫不出这个样子
Jake: I think, I think I can't clean up like this.
Alice:啊真的吗
Alice: Ah, really?
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:觉得已经很猛了
Jake: I think it's already great.
Alice:这些锅碗瓢不知啥是我们买的
Alice: Are these pots and pans ours or his?
Alice:还是他这有的
Alice: Or does he have them?
Jake:唉
Jake: Sigh.
Jake:有一部分是我们买的
Jake: Some of them are what we bought.
Alice:关键这也拿走没啥用啊
Alice: The key is, taking them isn't useful.
Jake:想拿就拿
Jake: Take them if you want.
Jake:随便拿点
Jake: Take whatever you want.
Katrina: 哎呦喝吃点西瓜又不太舒服
Alice:拿来也没有用啊
Alice: Bringing it here won't help.
Alice:用不上主要是家不在这
Alice: It's useless because home isn't here.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:好来
Jake: Alright, come on.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Jake:亲自挂的亲自摘
Jake: You hung it yourself, you take it down yourself.
Tasha:别把我电脑踩了
Tasha: Don't step on my computer.
Tasha:踩吧
Tasha: Go ahead, step on it.
Jake:哎呦
Jake: Oh no.
Tasha:墙没坏吧
Tasha: The wall isn't damaged, right?
Jake:这个怎么让他
Jake: How do you make it...
Tasha:哎呦我的天呐
Tasha: Oh my God.
Tasha:你撕的真好
Tasha: You did a great job ripping it.
Jake:哎谢谢
Jake: Oh, thanks.
Tasha:不会把墙撕坏的
Tasha: You won't damage the wall by ripping it.
Tasha:这是纸胶带
Tasha: It's paper tape.
Jake:yeah
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh...
Tasha:明天再把被子和玩偶一收就完成了
Tasha: We'll finish by packing the blankets and toys tomorrow.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:哎呦我靠哎呀呀
Jake: Oh no, ouch!
Jake:有
Jake: Got it.
Jake:在门口的纸箱
Jake: The box at the door.
Jake:就是大门口
Jake: Right at the main door.
Jake:收拾完了哦
Jake: All cleaned up.
Jake:哦 你有几个箱子得带着走不
Jake: Oh, do you need to take a few boxes with you?
Tasha:寄回去
Tasha: I'll mail them back.
Jake:寄 怎么寄
Jake: Mail them? How?
Jake:怎么寄 就是顺顺风上门吧
Jake: How to mail them? Just have Shunfeng pick them up?
Tasha:顺风上门
Tasha: Shunfeng will pick them up.
Jake:顺风上门明天约很多顺风上门是吧
Jake: Shunfeng pick up, scheduling a lot of Shunfeng pickups tomorrow, right?
Jake:好好好
Jake: Alright, alright, alright.
Jake:装家累还是拆家累
Jake: Is packing up the house tiring or is unpacking it more tiring?
Lucia:都挺累
Lucia: Both are tiring.
Jake:都挺累
Jake: Both are tiring.
Lucia:而且关键我那个老掉
Lucia: And the key thing is mine keeps falling apart.
Lucia:所以相当于我造了好多遍
Lucia: So it's like I built it many times.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:但是你
Jake: But you...
Jake:你现在可以拆家了
Jake: You can tear the house down now.
Jake:那可没法装
Jake: There's no way to install it.
Lucia:所以比格会拆家
Lucia: So Beagle will tear the house down?
Jake:但是你怎么装
Jake: But how will you install it?
Jake:你没法装
Jake: You can't install it.
Jake:拆了之后你还能装上吗
Jake: Can you install it after tearing it down?
Lucia:他可能不一定按照你期望的方式拆哦
Lucia: He might not tear it down the way you expect.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:一些出其不意的拆法
Lucia: Some unexpected ways of tearing down.
Jake:呃 为什么呀
Jake: Uh, why?
Lucia:我申请楼下支援一个箱子
Lucia: I applied for a box support downstairs.
Jake:为什么没声呢
Jake: Why is there no sound?
Jake:一点声都没有啦
Jake: There's no sound at all.
Jake:你在试试
Jake: Try again.
Tasha: 常年不用手电桶坏了
Tasha: The flashlight barrel broke from not being used for years.
Tasha: 哦哈哈
Tasha: Oh, haha.
Alice:你要
Alice: You want...
Alice:需要帮忙收拾东西吗
Alice: Need help packing things up?
Jake:柯欣什么时候
Jake: When is Kexin...
Lucia:需要你来陪我玩
Lucia: Need you to play with me.
Alice:啊
Alice: Huh?
Lucia:需要你来陪我玩
Lucia: Need you to play with me.
Alice:玩 玩什么
Alice: Play? Play what?
Lucia:玩
Lucia: Play.
Alice:猫捉老鼠
Alice: Cat and mouse.
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Huh?
Lucia:可以谁当猫谁当老鼠
Lucia: We can decide who will be the cat and who will be the mouse.
Jake: 猫捉老鼠
Jake: Cat and mouse.
Alice:我当狗反正
Alice: I'll be the dog anyway.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia:我要把这个拿上去
Lucia: I need to take this upstairs.
Lucia:要跟我一起来吗
Lucia: Want to come with me?
Alice:可以我可以帮你们收拾
Alice: Sure, I can help you guys pack.
Alice:我差不多了
Alice: I'm almost done.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Alice:你需要吗
Alice: Do you need it?
Tasha:我收拾完了
Tasha: I finished packing.
Lucia:嗯大家都这么快
Lucia: Hmm, everyone is so quick.
Tasha:用下油
Tasha: Use some oil.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Okay.
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake:我要把相机拆了来
Jake: I'm going to take the camera apart.
Jake:看看怎么拆
Jake: Let's see how to disassemble it.
Tasha:我吗
Tasha: Me?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake:我不知道怎么拆相机
Jake: I don't know how to take the camera apart.
Tasha:你不知道我怎么知道呢
Tasha: If you don't know, how would I know?
Jake:要不然就直接这么
Jake: Why don't we just do it directly like this?
Jake:要不然就直接卸了吧
Jake: Or just remove it directly.
Tasha:就这样吗
Tasha: Just like this?
Jake:这个东西要给他弄下来
Jake: We need to get this thing off.
Jake:但是我不知道怎么弄下来
Jake: But I don't know how to take it off.
Tasha:这不是直接双面胶粘吗
Tasha: Isn't it just stuck with double-sided tape?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Tasha:粘这么牢
Tasha: Stuck so firmly.
Tasha:这个好像可以直接
Tasha: This seems like it can be directly...
Jake:这个是得要那个小铲子吗
Jake: Do we need a small scraper for this?
Jake:这胶粘的确实结实啊
Jake: This tape is really solid.
Jake:不会掉呵呵
Jake: It won't come off, haha.
Jake:所以现在就不会掉
Jake: So it won't come off now.
Jake:没有一点办法
Jake: There's no way to get it off.
Tasha:你不是把人家房间给破坏了吗
Tasha: Didn't you just destroy someone's room?
Jake:我没有破坏我现在
Jake: I didn't destroy it, I'm just...
Tasha:那个胶绝对撕不下来了
Tasha: That tape definitely won't come off.
Jake:那真的吗
Jake: Really?
Jake:哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my god.
Jake:机
Jake: The camera...
Jake:可以
Jake: It's fine.
Jake:不要编号
Jake: Don't number it.
Jake:呃 啊
Jake: Uh, ah.
Jake:我来我来我来我来我来
Jake: Let me, let me, let me, let me.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Jake:嗯我是得买个铲子吧
Jake: Hmm, I think I need to buy a scraper.
Jake:种挖的那种
Jake: The kind for digging.
Jake:那叫什么呀水泥浆
Jake: What's it called, cement trowel?
Tasha:那你用提拉米苏的铲子行不行
Tasha: Can you use a tiramisu spatula?
Jake:试试试试试试
Jake: Let's try, let's try, let's try.
Jake:菜刀行吧
Jake: How about a kitchen knife?
Jake:嘿嘿 为什么
Jake: Hehe, why?
Jake:哎哟 我草
Jake: Oh my, damn.
Jake:呃 我试试 我觉得
Jake: Uh, I'll try. I think...
Jake:我来我来我来
Jake: Let me, let me, let me.
Tasha:好啦你要不先把三楼那些的拆下来我来想办法
Tasha: Okay, why don't you take down the stuff on the third floor first, and I'll figure something out.
Jake:真的吗
Jake: Really?
Jake:因为我先试到它的边缘至少
Jake: Because I first tried to reach its edge at least.
Lucia:没有
Lucia: No.
Lucia:但是我肯定明天就回家了
Lucia: But I'm definitely going home tomorrow.
Lucia:我查了一下
Lucia: I checked.
Lucia:从咱们这到北京西站大概一个多小时
Lucia: From here to Beijing West Station, it's about an hour or so.
Jake:哎呦我去撕下来
Jake: Oh, I'll just tear it off.
Jake:这个咱就不弄了
Jake: Let's not mess with this.
Jake:那咱就先试试
Jake: Let's just try first.
Jake:或者我打个电话
Jake: Or I'll make a call.
Jake:我我我拍个照问问吧
Jake: I'll take a picture and ask.
Jake:万一你们会弄
Jake: Maybe you guys can figure it out.
Jake:他们知道我们这么贴的
Jake: They know how we stick it on.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha:能交给你们来清理吗
Tasha: Can I leave the cleanup to you guys?
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake:好我来拆相机
Jake: Alright, I'll take apart the camera.
Jake:行吧
Jake: Okay?
Alice:可以做什么
Alice: What can I do?
Jake:啊帮我拆相机
Jake: Uh, help me take apart the camera.
Alice:ok
Alice: OK.
Jake:呃哎包包哎
Jake: Uh, hey, the bag, hey.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Damn.
Alice:怎么啦
Alice: What's wrong?
Jake:嗯拆完
Jake: Hmm, done taking it apart.
Alice:趁我走之前
Alice: Before I leave.
Jake:你什么时候走
Jake: When are you leaving?
Alice:我嗯今天晚上
Alice: Uh, tonight.
Jake:吃完饭走是吧
Jake: After dinner, right?
Alice:嗯对
Alice: Yeah, right.
Lucia:吃吧吃吧
Lucia: Eat, eat.
Jake:你不是点了吗
Jake: Didn't you order?
Jake:你不吃
Jake: Aren't you eating?
Alice:点过了
Alice: I ordered already.
Alice:但是我你要说具体几点的话那无所谓
Alice: But if you want to say a specific time, it doesn't matter to me.
Jake:ok
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 就转转先
Jake: Just spin it first.
Jake:先给它转一下
Jake: Spin it a bit first.
Jake:呃右边有一个是的
Jake: Uh, there's one on the right, yes.
Lucia:那我来拆这个好不好
Lucia: Can I take this apart?
Jake:好好好谢谢
Jake: Sure, sure, sure, thanks.
Lucia:那么我就上桌了
Lucia: Then I'll go to the table.
Jake:上桌
Jake: Go to the table.
Lucia:哎呀好激动呀
Lucia: Oh, I'm so excited.
Lucia:好久没有上过桌了哈哈哈
Lucia: It's been a long time since I've been at the table, hahaha.
Lucia:所以是是就是撕下来么
Lucia: So, just tear it off, right?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake:呃你你先拽下来你先把相机拽下来
Jake: Uh, you, you pull it down first, pull the camera down first.
Lucia:先把相机
Lucia: Pull the camera first.
Jake:拽拽拽拽
Jake: Pull, pull, pull.
Jake:它有一个这个口
Jake: There's a slot here.
Alice:哎呦我的天呐
Alice: Oh my god.
Lucia:这样吗
Lucia: Like this?
Jake:还有一个这个东西
Jake: There's also this thing.
Alice:老板
Alice: Boss.
Alice:这个要是粘真的粘在墙上都得赔死了
Alice: If this gets stuck on the wall, it would be a disaster.
Jake:那可不能粘在墙
Jake: It can't get stuck on the wall.
Alice:巨巨黏
Alice: It's super sticky.
Jake: 对吧
Jake: Right?
Alice:确实
Alice: Indeed.
Lucia:哦我知道你说的哪个了嗯
Lucia: Oh, I know which one you're talking about, mm-hmm.
Alice:这个怎么弄呢
Alice: How do you do this?
Lucia:我可以先把这个线
Lucia: Can I take this wire first?
Lucia:这线线连相机这头
Lucia: This wire is connected to the camera.
Lucia:我可以拔吗
Lucia: Can I unplug it?
Jake: 可以拔
Jake: You can unplug it.
Lucia:因为感觉这个钮不是特别好转
Lucia: Because this knob is not turning well.
Lucia:别我别我把线给它转断了
Lucia: Don't want to break the wire.
Katrina: 那个卫生所在哪我有点难受想去看下
Katrina: Where's the clinic? I'm feeling a bit unwell and want to check it out.
Lucia:什么锁
Lucia: What clinic?
Lucia:卫生所在
Lucia: The clinic is...
Lucia:我给你发个定位吧
Lucia: I'll send you the location.
Alice:你怎么了
Alice: What's wrong with you?
Katrina: 我还是有点拉肚子不知道为什么
Katrina: I still have a bit of diarrhea, not sure why.
Lucia:啊这个现在也不会不会掉下来
Lucia: Ah, this won't fall now.
Alice:这个你打车去很慢
Alice: If you take a cab, it'll be slow.
Alice:就是走路去很近
Alice: It's really close if you walk.
Lucia:这现在不会掉下来吧
Lucia: This won't fall now, right?
Lucia:我把这个取下来
Lucia: I'll take this down.
Jake:啊啊啊
Jake: Ah, ah, ah.
Alice:哎呦我的妈
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Jake:哇靠
Jake: Wow.
Lucia:我我去给雨轩发一下那个定位去
Lucia: I'll send Yuxuan the location.
Jake:咱陪他一起去
Jake: Let's go with him.
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia:要不然我送他过去
Lucia: Or I can take him.
Lucia:因为我走过一次
Lucia: Because I've walked there once.
Lucia:我比较熟
Lucia: I'm familiar with it.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:哎呦这个真的
Lucia: Oh, this is really...
Alice:这个黏的
Alice: This is sticky.
Jake:哎呦我靠
Jake: Oh, wow.
Jake:这个这个
Jake: This, this...
Lucia:我之前是发给发给那个同学
Lucia: I sent it to that classmate before.
Lucia:叫什么来着
Lucia: What's their name again?
Lucia:就是染了头发
Lucia: The one who dyed their hair.
Alice:XBZ
Alice: XBZ.
Lucia:一下想不起来了
Lucia: I can't remember right now.
Lucia:有点着急
Lucia: I'm a bit anxious.
Jake:竹哥
Jake: Zhu Ge.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh dear.
Alice:好难呢
Alice: This is so hard.
Lucia:找找一下我刚才的聊天记录
Lucia: Let me check my chat history.
Jake:他现在是我哥
Jake: He's my bro now.
Jake:这这你你是我姐一样
Jake: And you, you're like my sis.
Jake:哈哈 牛逼 哎呦
Jake: Haha, awesome.
Alice:这个怎么弄下来
Alice: How do you take this off?
Alice:你可以给刘婷发个消息吗
Alice: Can you message Liu Ting?
Alice:让她上来帮忙
Alice: Ask her to come up and help.
Jake:对先咱先救人
Jake: Yeah, let's save people first.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:他在哪啊
Jake: Where is he?
Jake:刘婷
Jake: Liu Ting?
Alice:楼底下呢
Alice: Downstairs.
Jake:那一会要下去我叫她
Jake:嚯这个很顺利
Alice:这个粘空调上的
Jake:我来试试
Jake:let me try一下
Alice:你你试
Jake:我试试
Jake:我试试这个胶确实牛逼
Jake:这胶可贵了
Alice:try半天就try这么点
Lucia:呃我给你发了一个定位
Jake:咱一块去吧好
Jake:就这么粗暴
Alice:但是那个呢
Jake:不管
Alice:啊
Jake:没有
Jake:就这个这个
Jake:问问管别墅的人他们有没有法子
Jake:他们可能拆过这种东西
Jake: They might have dismantled something like this before.
Alice:什么干啥
Alice: What are you talking about?
Jake:就是我们撕完之后他剩下来一个
Jake: You know, after we tear it, there's a piece left.
Lucia:哦这个这个可能可以啊OK
Lucia: Oh, this might work, okay.
Jake:这个已经没了
Jake: This one's gone.
Jake:哦这个这个
Jake: Oh, this one.
Lucia:那个可能可以用
Lucia: That one might work.
Lucia:就是吹风机吹一下
Lucia: Just use a hairdryer.
Lucia:然后看能不能撕下来
Lucia: And see if we can peel it off.
Lucia:但是不是100%能成功
Lucia: But it might not be 100% successful.
Jake:OK OK问问他问问他
Jake: Okay, okay, ask them, ask them.
Jake:谢谢各位帮忙做苦力
Jake: Thanks everyone for helping out.
Jake:这纯纯大苦力
Jake: This is pure hard labor.
Jake:我又靠
Jake: Oh, damn.
Jake:这边卫生所设施怎么样
Jake: How are the health facilities here?
Lucia:呃呃好有点一言难尽
Lucia: Uh, it's a bit hard to describe.
Lucia:大家一会看一眼
Lucia: Everyone should take a look later.
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh.
Lucia:要不要采药吗
Lucia: Want to gather some herbs?
Jake:也可以采一下
Jake: You can also collect some.
Lucia:没事小小小小问题
Lucia: It's nothing, just a tiny problem.
Lucia:他们肯定那个什么
Lucia: They're definitely doing that thing.
Lucia:就是那个卫生所他在装修
Lucia: The health center is being renovated.
Alice:干啥
Alice: What are you doing?
Alice:你干什么来
Alice: What are you up to?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
刘婷:哈哈哈哈稍安勿躁
Liuting: Hahaha, calm down.
刘婷:稍安勿躁
Liuting: Calm down.
刘婷:我的
Liuting: My bad.
Alice:哈哈哈你别挡道
Alice: Hahaha, don't block the way.
Alice:要去要去医院哈哈哈
Alice: Gotta go to the hospital, hahaha.
Alice:老玩这抽象
Alice: Always playing this abstract stuff.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:你先坐那吧
Alice: You sit there first.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Alice:来来来
Alice: Come on, come on.
Alice:坐
Alice: Sit.
Alice:好
Alice: Good.
Alice:嗯待会还得下去
Alice: Yeah, we'll have to go down later.
Alice:哎
Alice: Ugh.
Jake:要大家捐
Jake: Everyone needs to donate.
Jake:捐几件衣服
Jake: Donate some clothes.
Jake:怕你冷着
Jake: So you don't get cold.
Alice:上面是不是拆完了
Alice: Is the top part done?
Jake:好谢谢
Jake: Okay, thanks.
Jake:就放到那桌上
Jake: Just put it on that table.
Alice:下面吧
Alice: Down there.
Jake:下面三人还是别拆了
Jake: The three below shouldn't be torn down.
Alice:告诉你一个消息
Alice: I have some news for you.
Alice:刘婷我要下去了
Alice: Liuting, I need to go down.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Alice:来
Alice: Come on.
刘婷:处心机虑把我骗下去
Liuting: You tricked me into coming down.
Alice:不是我没给你发消息
Alice: No, I didn't send you any messages.
Alice:你咋上来了
Alice: How did you come up?
刘婷:因为
Liuting: Because...
Alice:你听见了
Alice: You heard it.
Lucia:哦你不是让我给刘婷发消息么
Lucia: Oh, didn't you ask me to send a message to Liuting?
Alice:对啊我还以为我俩的脑电波交流了
Alice: Yeah, I thought we were communicating telepathically.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:那是真的
Jake: That's real.
Katrina: 你们先去拿下外卖
Katrina: You guys go get the takeout first.
Alice:我我我去吧
Alice: I'll go, I'll go.
Jake:你你别动啊
Jake: No, you stay put.
Jake:你你
Jake: You, you...
Alice:我去吧
Alice: I'll go.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Alice:她在哪啊
Alice: Where is she?
Katrina: 53号房
Katrina: Room 53.
Jake:雨轩你在哪
Jake: Yuxuan, where are you?
Alice:53号房在哪
Alice: Where is Room 53?
Katrina: 我就不能吃东西的
Katrina: I just can't eat anything.
Alice:你是不是急性
Alice: Are you having acute...
Jake:你现在又好了是吧
Jake: Are you feeling better now?
Alice:肠胃炎呢
Alice: Gastroenteritis?
Alice:可能是感觉像是
Alice: It feels like that.
Katrina: 还有不舒服
Katrina: Still feeling uncomfortable.
Jake:你先坐着歇着你别乱跑啊
Jake: You sit and rest, don't run around.
Alice:5 53号楼在哪里
Alice: Where is Building 53?
Katrina: 就
Katrina: Just...
Jake:啊我去那里我去领我去
Jake: Ah, I'll go there, I'll pick it up, I'll go.
Jake:你你歇着 你别 你搞什么搞
Jake: You, you rest, don't, what are you doing?
Jake:哎左拐
Jake: Hey, turn left.
Jake:左拐对
Jake: Turn left, yes.
Jake:哎 嗯
Jake: Hey, hmm.
Jake:就你第一回拿快递
Jake: Is this your first time picking up a package?
Alice:不是
Alice: No.
Jake:第一回拿外卖
Jake: First time getting takeout?
Alice:不是啊
Alice: No.
Jake:那那那你没点53
Jake: Then why didn't you find Room 53?
Alice:但是他说53我就不知道在哪
Alice: But when he said 53, I didn't know where it was.
Jake:我31他到门口去了
Jake: I'm at 31, he went to the entrance.
Jake:这就是53
Jake: This is 53.
Alice:都是他们家的吗
Alice: Is it all their place?
Jake:对这一排都是他们家
Jake: Yes, this whole row is theirs.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:是53
Jake: It's 53.
Jake:那馄饨是吗
Jake: The wontons, right?
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thank you.
Jake:没了
Jake: That's it.
Alice:没了
Alice: That's it.
Jake:慢走 有吧
Jake: Take care, got it?
Jake:啊 有啊 哎呦
Jake: Oh, got it. Oh!
Jake:您这跑多远
Jake: How far did you run?
Jake:这个这单多远
Jake: How far is this order?
外卖员:是讲你们这个啊
Delivery Guy: You mean this one?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
外卖员:应该没多完
Delivery Guy: Shouldn't be too far.
Jake:就在那环湖那
Jake: It's around the lake.
Jake:拜拜
Jake: Bye-bye.
Alice:这一排都是他们家
Alice: This whole row belongs to their family.
Jake:啊  说什么
Jake: Huh? What did you say?
Lucia:我们去卫生所
Lucia: We're going to the clinic.
Lucia:路上还要需要录这个吗
Lucia: Do we need to record this on the way?
Lucia:还是可以停掉之类的
Lucia: Or can we stop it or something?
Jake:你再带着吧
Jake: Just keep it on.
Jake:带着没电拉倒了就
Jake: If it runs out of battery, then whatever.
Lucia:哈哈哈 行行 那
Lucia: Haha, alright then.
Lucia:呃那个不远
Lucia: Uh, it's not far.
Alice:走路十分钟吧
Alice: About a ten-minute walk.
Lucia:那我先把雨轩送过去
Lucia: I'll take Yuxuan over first.
Jake:好 有什么要帮忙的我们就冲过去啊
Jake: Okay, if you need help, we'll come running.
Jake:暂且我们先派您一个
Jake: For now, we'll send you one person.
Jake:带了伞吗 他们
Jake: Did they bring umbrellas?
Alice:带了
Alice: Yes, they did.
Jake:吃饭
Jake: Let's eat.
Jake:吃两口走
Jake: Eat a bit and then go.
Jake:没关系
Jake: It's okay.
Jake:走走
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake: 给您端馄饨
Jake: I'll bring you some wontons.
Alice: 这个需要先关掉吗
Alice: Should I turn this off?
Alice: 哪一个
Alice: Which one?
Alice:这些
Alice: These?
Jake:这些
Jake: These.
Jake: 不 这些这些
Jake: No, these, these.
Jake: 等到他们没
Jake: Until they...
Jake: 呃没没没story了
Jake: Uh, no more story...
Jake: 就停止
Jake: Then stop.
Jake: 让他们再贡献最后一些小数据
Jake: Let them contribute a few more small data points.
Alice:力量
Alice: Strength
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah
Jake: 嗯我不知道哪个是我的呀
Jake: Hmm, I don't know which one is mine
Alice: 等下啊 这是不要香菜的
Alice: Wait a minute, this one doesn't have cilantro
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay
Jake: 我们有很多不要香菜的
Jake: We have a lot without cilantro
Alice: 你是哪个
Alice: Which one is yours?
Tasha:我没要
Tasha: I didn't order
Alice:你没点吗
Alice: You didn't order?
Jake: 她没点但是嗯
Jake: She didn't order but...
刘婷:没事的没事 饿了给你 匀一碗
Liu Ting: It's okay, it's okay, if you're hungry, I'll share a bowl with you
Alice: 匀点 你要香菜还是不要
Alice: Share some, do you want cilantro or not?
Tasha:我不要的
Tasha: I don't want any
Alice: 啊那我们都可以给你匀
Alice: Ah, then we can all share with you
Jake: 别选雨萱的 没法吃
Jake: Don't pick Yuxuan's, it's inedible
Alice: 他是什么时候开始的
Alice: When did it start?
Jake:她  我不知道时候开始的
Jake: She, I don't know when it started
Jake: 她是想吃这个
Jake: She wants to eat this
Jake: 但是她已经上卫生所
Jake: But she already went to the clinic
Jake: 并且她应该吃了她就吐所以没法吃
Jake: And if she eats it, she'll throw up, so she can't eat
Alice:看上去像肠胃炎
Alice: Looks like gastroenteritis
Jake: 一般是吃坏了还是怎么着
Jake: Usually from eating something bad or what?
Alice: 不一定很多吧
Alice: Not necessarily, could be many things
Alice: 主要是肠胃
Alice: Mainly the stomach
Tasha:吃太杂了吧好像是
Tasha: Ate too much variety, I guess
Jake: 哦伙食太好了
Jake: Oh, the meals are too good
Tasha:这点菜一点叶子也没有
Tasha: This dish doesn't have any leaves
Alice: 嗯可能是
Alice: Hmm, maybe
Jake: 真的
Jake: Really
Alice: 就容易缺维生素之类的
Alice: It's easy to lack vitamins and such
Alice:下巴老冒痘
Alice: Constantly getting pimples on the chin
Jake:呃 对啊 怎么没有菜啊
Jake: Uh, yeah, why no veggies?
Jake: 中午今天中午有菜对吧
Jake: We had veggies for lunch, right?
Alice:今天中午吃的啥呀
Alice: What did we have for lunch today?
Tasha:这个 就点的那个
Tasha: This, just what we ordered
Alice: 哦有但是挺油的
Alice: Oh, but it was quite oily
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright then
Jake:香菜
Jake: Cilantro
Tasha:没有
Tasha: No
Jake:是这个味
Jake: It’s this flavor
Tasha:没事
Tasha: It's okay.
Jake: 嗯那你那你别过来
Jake: Mm, then, then you don't come over.
Alice: 你是哪个
Alice: Which one are you?
Alice: 我也不知道你是哪个
Alice: I don't know which one you are either.
刘婷:嗯什么虾仁不要香菜的这两都是
Liu Ting: Um, both of these shrimp dishes don't have cilantro.
Alice: 都不要香菜的吧
Alice: None of them have cilantro, right?
Jake: 你怎么知道的
Jake: How do you know?
Alice: 没有那个绿色
Alice: There's no green stuff.
Alice: 这俩都没啊
Alice: Neither of these have it.
刘婷:是不是在汤里呀
Liu Ting: Is it in the soup?
Tasha:就没有啊
Tasha: There isn't any.
刘婷:啊没事我要不要香菜其实都可以
Liu Ting: Oh, it's okay, I actually don't mind cilantro.
Jake: 不是就是这馅怎么看啊
Jake: No, but how do you tell from the filling?
刘婷:这馅 应该是肉馅
Liu Ting: The filling should be meat.
Jake: 有很多种肉馅吧
Jake: There are many kinds of meat fillings, right?
Tasha:那也没菜啊
Tasha: But there are no vegetables.
Alice:没纸
Alice: There's no paper.
Jake: 哦你想吃菜是吧
Tasha:我不想吃菜
Tasha: I don't want to eat veggies.
Jake: 这个是菜
Jake: This is a veggie dish.
刘婷:哦不是我真不吃
Liu Ting: Oh no, I really don't eat veggies.
Jake: 那你好吧
Jake: Alright, you're good.
Tasha:我把露亚的吃了应该
Tasha: I think I ate Lucia's.
Jake: 你咋知道这是露亚的
Jake: How do you know it's Lucia's?
Tasha:我猜的
Tasha: I guessed.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Alice: 这个虾仁的
Alice: This one is shrimp.
Jake: 我不记得我点的是啥
Jake: I don't remember what I ordered.
Jake: 剩下的就给我吧
Jake: Just give me the rest.
Jake: 你不吃
Jake: You're not eating?
Alice: 我靠香菜
Alice: I can't handle cilantro.
Jake: 给你吃一个吧
Jake: Have one.
Alice: 香菜哈
Alice: With cilantro, huh?
Alice: 就这样吧随便了
Alice: Alright, whatever.
刘婷:没事反正也没有很多吧
Liu Ting: It's okay, there isn't much anyway.
Jake: 哎哎哎哎哎
Jake: Hey, hey, hey.
刘婷:慢点慢点
Liu Ting: Slow down, slow down.
Jake: 哎哎
Jake: Hey, hey.
Jake: 哎 我来我来
Alice: 这样吧我抽到了香菜款
Alice: Alright, I got the cilantro one.
Tasha:原来香菜在下面
Tasha: Oh, the cilantro is at the bottom.
Alice:嗯就这样吧
Alice: Yeah, just like that.
Jake: 给张纸是吧
Jake: Can you give me a piece of paper?
Alice:那你的虾仁吧
Alice: And here's your shrimp.
Jake: 我来问问XBZ他在干嘛
Jake: Let me ask XBZ what he's doing.
Tasha:他什么时时候来
Tasha: When is he coming?
Jake: 不知道
Jake: No idea.
Jake:这谁知道
Jake: Who knows.
Jake: 哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake: 哎竹哥竹哥竹哥
Jake: Hey, Zuke, Zuke, Zuke.
Jake: 你在哪啊
Jake: Where are you?
Jake: 竹哥 对
Jake: Zuke, right.
Nicous: 我在地铁上
Nicous: I'm on the subway.
Jake: 你一个人来的是吧
Jake: You came alone, right?
Nicous: 啊
Nicous: Yeah.
Jake: 你发烧你一个人坐地铁呢
Jake: You're riding the subway alone with a fever?
Jake: 你这么牛逼
Jake: You're so tough.
Nicous: 我烧退了
Nicous: My fever went down.
Jake: 你退你退烧了啊
Jake: Your fever went down?
Nicous: 呃
Nicous: Yeah.
Alice: 退烧了
Alice: The fever went down.
Jake:你退烧了啊
Jake: Your fever went down?
Tasha:马不停蹄跑过来打工
Tasha: Rushing over here to work right after.
Jake: 行行好好退
Jake: Okay, okay, calm down.
Nicous: 我过来是睡觉咧
Nicous: I came here to sleep.
Jake: 哈哈哈不
Jake: Hahaha, no.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha:过来睡觉啊
Tasha: Came here to sleep, huh?
Jake: 我不觉得你过来是睡觉的
Jake: I don't think you came here just to sleep.
Jake: 行吧
Jake: Alright then.
Nicous: ok
Nicous: Okay.
Jake: 呃你什么时候来的
Jake: So, when did you come?
Jake: 你什么时候到
Jake: When are you arriving?
Jake: 大概8点半
Jake: Around 8:30.
Tasha:你吃你吃晚饭了吗
Tasha: Did you have dinner yet?
Nicous: 我自己吃了
Nicous: I ate by myself.
Alice: 哎我们还可以点了吗
Alice: Hey, can we still order?
Jake: 哎可惜了只能帮你吃了
Jake: Oh, too bad, we'll just help you eat.
Jake: 好再见吧
Jake: Okay, bye then.
Nicous: 哈哈那我可以吃啊
Nicous: Haha, well, I can still eat.
Jake: 哈哈哈行拜拜
Jake: Hahaha, alright, bye-bye.
Jake: 拜拜拜拜拜拜
Jake: Bye-bye-bye-bye-bye.
Nicous: 拜拜
Nicous: Bye-bye.
Jake: 来来点来一个
Jake: Come on, have one.
Tasha:那我这个吃一个
Tasha: Then I'll have one of these.
Jake: 好
Jake: Sure.
Jake: 给给你个勺
Jake: Here, take a spoon.
Tasha:不用了我不用了
Tasha: No need, I don't need it.
Jake: 咱就不缺勺
Jake: We don't lack spoons.
Jake: 行给你个筷子
Jake: Okay, take some chopsticks.
Tasha:我也不用
Tasha: I don't need that either.
Jake: 好
Jake: Alright.
Tasha:唉不对那怎么吃
Tasha: Wait, then how do I eat?
Jake: 就是嘛
Jake: Exactly.
Tasha:啊谢谢
Tasha: Ah, thanks.
Jake: 啊我筷子刚给你弄好
Jake: I just got the chopsticks ready for you.
Jake: 你就好这个是是捎给你的是吧行
Jake: This is the one I got for you, right?
Jake: 好吃吗
Jake: Is it good?
Jake: 怎么一脸凝重
Jake: Why do you look so serious?
Alice: 呵呵嗯 不是
Alice: Haha, no, it's not that.
Tasha:这么难吃吗
Tasha: Is it that bad?
刘婷:因为抽到香菜款了
Liu Ting: Because it has cilantro in it.
Jake: 是吧
Jake: Really?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Jake: 香菜款所以不是
Jake: So it's the cilantro, huh?
Alice: 这个皮有点厚
Alice: The skin is a bit thick.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice: 你觉得呢
Alice: What do you think?
Jake: 没吃到呢
Jake: Haven't tasted it yet.
刘婷:但味道还行
Liu Ting: But the flavor is okay.
Jake: 你俩怎么认识的
Jake: How did you two meet?
Alice: 命中注定认识的
Alice: It was destined.
刘婷:我们俩谈恋爱认识的
Liu Ting: We met while dating.
Alice:我靠干嘛
Alice: Oh come on, really?
Jake:怎么怎么找着的
Jake: How did you find each other?
Alice: 阴差阳错当了邻居
Alice: By a twist of fate, we became neighbors.
Alice: 我真服了
Alice: I'm really speechless.
Alice: 我能换个位吗
Jake: 晚上发生的啥
Jake: What happened last night?
Alice: 什么晚上发生的
Alice: What happened last night?